in this video I'll be explaining what
discrete mathematics is and why it's
important for the field of computer
science and programming discrete
mathematics is a branch of mathematics
that deals with discrete or finite sets
of elements rather than continuous or
infinite sets of elements imagine trying
to run a program that requires an
infinite number of executions to
complete attacks it's obvious to say
that the program would run forever and
the task would never be completed
because there an infinite number of
executions in order to avoid this
problem we approximate the continuous
sets with discrete sets now you may be
thinking I never use math that involves
infinite sets but I promise that you do
the simplest example is with a circle a
circle by definition is an infinite
number of points equidistant from a
fixed point and the problem with this is
that if we try to write a program that
prints out all of these points they will
run forever because they're an infinite
number of points and therefore an
infinite number of executions so this is
physically impossible that's why if we
zoom in here
you can see that the when you come down
here there are all these points but in
reality we should have even more points
between these points and then if we zoom
in on those we'll have more points
between those points and we can never
complete the task now we've all seen
circles on computers so what's going on
how is this possible we just established
that it's impossible well the answer is
that they're approximations for example
consider regular polygons regular
polygons like a triangle or a square or
a Pentagon those don't really look like
circles but if you keep increasing the
number of vertices eventually you'll
start getting hexagons octagons
dodecagon x' hexa decagons
i cosas Gonz you can see that these
regular polygons the more or more you
keep increasing the number of vertices
which the vertices are equidistant from
a fixed point they will eventually
approximate a circle eventually they
will be indistinguishable to the naked
eye and will look identical to a circle